[音楽]
[拍手]
大切なことは目に見えない
この言葉を聞いて皆さん何を思い浮かべ
ますか
i ですか
電気ですか
星の王子様という人もいるかもしれません
人はどうしても目に見えるものを信じて
しまいがちです
この幸せそうな家族を見れば何の問題も
なく幸せに暮らしていると思いますよね
でもこの家族がどう大きな問題を抱えて
いるかもしれない
でもそれも目には見えません
目に見えているのは一部分だけで目に見え
ないものは勝手に都合のいいように想像し
てしまい月です
逆に目に見えないものを信じてもらうのは
本当に難しいことです
目に見えないから本当なのか
騙されてないのかと疑いやすくなって
しまう
目に見えないものを信じてもらうにはその
人自身を信じて守らなければなりません
ここで簡単な実験をしてみましょう
ここに黄色いボールがあります
このボールが黄色いと信じてくださる方は
どれくらいいますか
私はマジちゃんじゃないのでいきなり青に
変わったりはしません
ここに箱があります
この箱の中にも黄色いボールが同じ黄色い
ボールが入っています
さてっ
この中に同じ黄色いボールが入っていると
信じてくらいくださるからどれくらい
でしょう
青いボールが入っているかもしれませんし
そもそも何も入ってないかもしれません
さてそれでもこのボールこの箱の中に
黄色いボールが入っていると信じてくれ
くださる方どれ位いらっしゃいますか
はい答え合わせです
本当に黄色いボールが入っています
目にみっ目に見えないものを信じてもらう
にわたし自身を信じてもらわなければなら
ない
私が10年以上続けてきた目に見えない
ものの価値を提案する仕事を通して痛感し
てきたことです
私はし空気と紫外線という目に見えない
ものを扱う仕事をしています
ここに浮遊しているかもしれない
細菌やウイルスも目には見えません
こちらが私たちが開発した紫外線照射装置
です
この装置は実施ボックスくらいの大きさな
んですが
高さ2.1m 以上の高さに取り付けて
紫外線を水平に照射します
部屋の空気はゆっくり自然対流しているの
でこの紫外線のエリアにこの細菌や
ウイルスを組む空気を振れるか触れると
それを減少させることができます
紫外線を使っているので安全なのか
本当に当たらないのかと思う方も
いらっしゃるかもしれませんがこの紫外線
のリアと安全な生活空間をしっかり
コントロールすることができるので人には
紫外線が当たらず安心です
この空気の質を上げるということを私たち
は空気環境対策という風に呼んでいます
この空気環境対策を社会のインフラにして
私は私は心身健康に暮らせる世界を作り
たいという風に考えています
皆さんお水を買って飲んだりしたことが
ありますよね
一昔前まではお水を買うという文化があり
ませんでした
水技口をひねればタダで飲めるので
わざわざお金を出してまで買うものでは
なかったからです
空気も同じでほとんどタダのようなものと
思われてきました
でも今回のパンデミックを受けて
空気も何か対策をしているかどうかという
ことがお店や施設を選ぶひとつの基準に
なりつつあります
そうですこの四輪質の良い空気を選んで
買う時代が来たということです
この製品を開発を始めたのは15年以上前
のことで作ったが良かったんですがこれを
清めるということが想像絶するほど難しく
表よりも苦しい時期が長く続きました
始めほとんど売れなかったです
さて皆さんは風邪をひいたことがあると
思います
風邪はウイルスや細菌による感染症のこと
です
市場空気を介して感染します
この目に見えない空気を対策をすることで
守れるかもしれない健康や持っていると命
があります
空気環境対策の重要性私はずっと感じてき
ましたが世の中はそうではありませんでし
た
そんなの必要ないよう遠い返されて話し
たらそもそも聞いてもらえませんでした
背後施設や病院保育園や幼稚園など
こんな5-多くの施設ではいつも何かしら
の感染症が流行しています
何かしらの対策をしていてそれがだいたい
飛沫感染が摂政関西の大作ばかりで空気の
対策はほとんど無かったことにされて
しまうんです
以前印象的な出来事がありました
ある介護施設に私がこの空気環境対策の
重要性について熱く語ったところそこの
経営者の方にこんな風に言われたんです
うちはパフォーマンスいいから
最初は何言ってんだろうと思いました
富貴製造機の効果があまり期待出来なくて
も
お客様や患者さんへの pr として
パフォーマンスとして
この空気をキレイにしている感じが伝われ
ばそれでいいって言うんです
私は画然としました人の命を
事実の道具にしてるんだと
ここ経営者の家族が大切な家族がこの介護
施設を入居者だったら本当にそんなこと
言えると思いますか
私はきっと言えないと思います
目には見えてるんだけどそこに目に見え
ないけれどそこに気づいている
それなのに都合が悪ければ無かったことに
してしまう
そのせいで誰かの健康や命に影響があるか
もしれないのにこんな悔しい思いを私は
ずっとしてきました
製品を売るという以前にこの目に見えない
価値に気付いてもらう難しさを痛感しまし
た
今私はこの空気環境対策をインフラにする
という使命感に燃えてやっていますが最初
からこんな風にこんな風ではなかったん
です
事業が苦しかった時にある先輩からこう
言われました
気迫がやっていることは正しいんだから
ずっとやるべきだよ
でもこの
この事業が社会にとって本当に重要なこと
か
私も混乱するほど悩んでいた時期もあり
ました
また別の先輩からこんな風にやりました
キャラ君自身の覚悟が決まってないんだぞ
うまくいかないの
自分のせいではなく
これを理解してくれない誰かのせいだと
思っていた私にはっとさせられるような
一言でした
このメニーにこんなときにもう1回自分を
信じようと思ったんです
私はこの人の命を救えるかもしれないと
いう使命感でこの事業への参画を決めまし
た
そのときの気持ちを思い出してもう1回穴
浴衣もと固まったところ
だんだんと周りの人が応援してくれるよう
になってきたんです
例えば銀行に融資をしてもらう時にもある
人は仕事とは全く関係ないのに事業計画を
一緒に考えてくれたりいろんな人私に協力
してくれました
こんな協力してくれた皆さんの優しさ
思いやりも目には見えません
この皆さんのや再生思いやりが私がどん底
からはい上がり勇気をくれました
この目に見えない見えづらい気づきづらい
もの中に本当に重要なことがたくさん
埋もれています
多くの人は見えるものや
今日動くものには興味があるのに見えない
ものにはほとんど興味がありません
見えないからやらなくていい
めんどくさい見えないから仕方ないと思っ
ていて知ろうともしないということが往々
にしてあります
この見えないものを見る努力をしていか
ないと大変なことになるという危機感を私
はこの空気環境対策の事業を通して感じて
きました
今回のパンデミックで世界中の人が経験し
たように
人というのは異変に直面しないとなかなか
行動変えようと水いうことには長田
結びついていかないんです
一つ今回のワクチンを例にとってみ
ましょう
ワクチンを海外で打ち始めたとき
その情報を調べた人がどれくらいだ
でしょうか
本当に打つべきなのか打たないべきなのか
いろんな情報を調べたりしたのは
自分の大切な家族がワクチンの接種券を手
にした時という人も多かったんじゃない
でしょうか
私も
ここ数ヶ月
たくさんの友人から相談を受けましたが
みんなやっぱり自分の家族に期限が迫って
初めて行動を起こしたように思います
をの図を見てください
自分がいて
周りに大切な人知っている人知らない人と
いて多くの人は知らない人に異変が迫って
もなかなか行動を変えるということはあり
ません
知っている人に異変が迫っても少しは気に
なると思うんですが
自分の行動を変えるまでには少し腰がも
たいんじゃないでしょうか
ほどように
自分の大切な人に
威厳が迫って初めて見えないものを見よう
としたり考え始めたり行動か a たり
しようとするんです
自分の大切な人のことを考えれば目に見え
ないものでもその重要性に目を向けるよう
になります例えばお子さんや自分の大切な
人のことを考えることは未来を考えること
です
私たちは大切な人のためでなければ力が出
なかったり行動は変わらない部分があると
思います
まずは大切な人のことを考えましょう
きっと今まで見えなかったことに気づいて
行動を変えることができると思います
でもわたしのおおきな理想いうとこの大切
な人を知っている人知らない人は境界線を
なくして知らない人でも自分の大切な人と
同じように考えることができれば世界は
もっとよくなると思います
たとえば白なぁばあちゃんが道に迷ってい
たらあなたはどうしますか
困っているから助ける人もいるかもしれ
ないし助けない人もいるかもしれません
もしこのおばあちゃんが誰かにとっては
大切な人でもし自分のおばあちゃんだっ
たらと思うことができたらどうでしょうか
優しく接してあげるんじゃないでしょうか
こんな大切な人にするように他の人に
接することを少し意識してみてください
境界線をなくすというのはほんのちょっと
したことなんです
この境界性をなくすことができたら社会を
もっと良くなっていくと信じています人を
大切に思う気持ちを広げることができれば
大きな思いやりの輪が広がっていくんじゃ
ないでしょうか
今私たちは見えるものばかりに関心がある
ような気がしてます結果
大切な人を見失わ大切なものを見失って目
に見えない多くに支えられていることに
気づかなくなってしまっているんじゃない
でしょうか
地球環境問題やその他の社会課題など
世の中には目に見えないけれど命生活未来
に関わる重要なことがたくさんあります
今回のパンデミックで社会がこんなにも
大きなダメージを負ってしまったのも目に
見えないことの重要性に餌を向けてこ
なかったからというのも一理あるんじゃ
ないでしょうか
この目に見えない重要性に気づいたら
平和で安全あり思いやりにあふれた世界に
なると私は信じています
空気はウイルスは目に見えません
他にも目に見えないものはたくさんあり
ます
でも目に見えないものの重要性に気づいて
その本質を知ろうと努力をすれば私たちの
ミラーが確実に変わっていきます
目に見えないものの中に本当に大切なもの
がある
あなたは大切な人のためにどんな行動を
起こしますか
ありがとうございました
[拍手]